Here's our square with a few slider controls. I can scale the polygon to be
larger in either dimension. The texture stretches to fit. What's more
interesting is what happens when I change the u or v values. Here I'm changing
the u value of the two points on the right edge. The value starts at one. If I
increase the value, this has the effect of putting more copies of the texture
along that axis. Let's switch to the mosaic texture. If I decrease the value of
v, less of a texture is mapped to the square. I can do the same thing with u.
This is how mosaicing works. Each triangle is given some fractional u and v
values that select the piece of the texture needed. Give this demo a try and
get a sense of how the values affect the rectangle and texture.